The U.S. population as a whole is getting older. By 2034, people over 65 will outnumber children for the first time in U.S. history. And the fastest growing segment of the population is those over age 85. For most people lucky enough to live that long, aging comes with some cognitive decline. Our memories just aren't as sharp at age 85 as they were at 45, 55, or 65. But cognitive decline isn't universal. Some people, known as super-agers, have cognitive abilities that remain intact into their 80s, 90s, and even beyond. So what sets these super-agers apart?
美国人口整体正在老龄化。到2034年，65岁以上人口将首次超过儿童人口，成为美国历史上首次。而人口中增长最快的部分是85岁以上的老人。对于大多数有幸活到这个岁数的人来说，衰老伴随着一定的认知能力下降。我们在85岁时的记忆力确实不如45岁、55岁或65岁时那么敏锐。但认知能力下降并非普遍现象。有些人被称为“超级老人”，他们的认知能力在80岁、90岁甚至更久之后依然保持完好。那么，是什么让这些“超级老人”与众不同呢？
Do they just have lucky genes? How do their brains differ from the brains of people who age in a more typical way? Is it something about the way they've lived their lives, a better diet, more sleep, more exercise, that allows their brains to seem to escape the ravages of time? Or is it a combination of these factors? and what might we learn from studying super-agers that could potentially help the rest of us to age better? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
他们只是拥有幸运的基因吗？他们的大脑与那些以更典型方式衰老的人的大脑有何不同？是因为他们的生活方式、更好的饮食、更多的睡眠、更多的锻炼，才使得他们的大脑似乎逃脱了时间的摧残吗？还是这些因素的综合作用？通过研究“超级老人”，我们能学到什么，从而可能帮助我们其他人更好地老去？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Emily Rogalski, a clinical and cognitive neuroscientist and professor of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at Northwestern University's Feinberg School of Medicine. For more than a decade, Dr. Rogalski has led the super aging study, working with hundreds of older adults in the Chicago area, all over age 80, who have the memory capacity of people at least three decades younger. She'll talk to us today about what she and other researchers have learned from these superagers. In addition to her work with them, Dr. Rogalski is interested more broadly in aging and dementia. She uses brain imaging and other techniques to study different dementia syndromes, and she develops education. programs, support groups, and internet-based therapies to improve the quality of life for patients with dementia.
我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是艾米丽·罗加尔斯基博士，她是西北大学范伯格医学院的临床与认知神经科学家，也是精神病学和行为科学教授。十多年来，罗加尔斯基博士一直领导着“超级老龄化研究”，与芝加哥地区数百名80岁以上的老年人合作，他们的记忆力相当于至少年轻三十岁的人。今天，她将与我们分享她和其他研究人员从这些“超级老人”身上学到的知识。除了与他们合作外，罗加尔斯基博士还更广泛地关注衰老和痴呆症。她利用脑成像和其他技术研究不同的痴呆症综合征，并开发教育项目、支持小组和基于互联网的疗法，以提高痴呆症患者的生活质量。
Thank you for joining us, Dr. Rogalski. Thanks for having me. I'm so pleased to be here. I just mentioned that the super ages in your study are required to be at least 80 years old with the memory abilities of people in their 50s or 60s. How did you decide that that was the definition of super aging? It harkens back to what you talked about in your intro and really thinking about, gosh, what happens when we we age. And a lot of the news is not so positive. We talk about all the bad things that happen with aging. And our center in specific is focused on cognition and the brain and how the brain works. And what we know about cognition in aging is that there does on average tend to be decline.
感谢您加入我们，罗加尔斯基博士。谢谢邀请我。我很高兴来到这里。我刚才提到，您研究中的“超级老人”要求至少80岁，且拥有50多岁或60多岁人的记忆能力。您是如何确定这就是“超级老龄化”的定义的？这回到了您在开场白中提到的内容，即真正思考当我们变老时会发生什么。很多新闻并不那么积极。我们谈论的都是衰老带来的坏事。我们的中心特别关注认知和大脑，以及大脑是如何工作的。我们所知道的是，在衰老过程中，认知能力平均而言确实倾向于下降。
And we know that that decline can be more precipitous past the age of 5560. And so by the time you get to age 80, the expected memory decline on average is quite striking between 80-year-olds and 1560-year-olds. So we selected age because it represents an age where people are at the greatest risk for loss of memory. And it's also the thing that people complain about the most is, I can't remember my keys or my memory is not as good as it used to be. And so these things, like really important things to zero in on. We also chose the age 80 because we are a nationally funded Alzheimer's Disease Center. And so part of our work is incredibly focused on aging and dementia. And Alzheimer's dementia, the most striking symptom is that loss of memory. So how unusual is it to be a super age?
我们知道，这种下降在55到60岁之后可能会更加剧烈。因此，当你到了80岁时，80岁老人与50到60岁老人之间的预期记忆力下降是非常显著的。所以我们选择了这个年龄，因为它代表了人们记忆力丧失风险最大的阶段。这也是人们抱怨最多的事情，比如“我不记得钥匙在哪了”或者“我的记忆力不如以前了”。所以这些是非常重要、值得重点关注的事情。我们选择80岁还因为我们是一个国家资助的阿尔茨海默病中心。因此，我们的部分工作非常专注于衰老和痴呆症。而阿尔茨海默病最显著的症状就是记忆力丧失。那么，成为一名“超级老人”有多罕见呢？
I mean, do you have a sense of the percentage of the population over age 80 that has these great memory abilities? Another excellent question and one that I get a lot. And unfortunately, the type of research we're doing is not epidemiologic in nature. And so let me unpack that a little bit. So it's not as if I have access to the medical records and contact with all of the 80-plus-year-olds across the United States or even the 80-plus-year-olds within Chicago. And that's the type of information I'd really need to understand what's the incidence and prevalence of super aging. But what we do have is our experience of people calling us and saying, hey, I'm over H-80, and I think I'm a superager. And then we bring them through that screening. And I can tell you that
我的意思是，您是否了解80岁以上人口中拥有这种出色记忆能力的人所占的比例？这是另一个极好的问题，也是我经常被问到的。遗憾的是，我们所做的研究本质上并非流行病学研究。让我稍微解释一下。我无法接触到全美甚至芝加哥地区所有80岁以上老人的医疗记录并与他们取得联系。而这正是了解“超级老龄化”发病率和患病率所需要的信息。但我们确实有人们打来电话说：“嘿，我超过80岁了，我觉得自己是一名‘超级老人’”的经验。然后我们带他们进行筛选。我可以告诉你，
we've screened thousands of individuals at this point. And we really recognize superaging as a rare phenotype. We think that it is not the mainstream, what we would call it. It wouldn't be common. So you're interested in figuring out what sets these superagers apart from other people, and one of the ways that you've done that is through brain imaging studies. What have you found? How are the brains of superagers different from those who have just normal memories? We have the superagers in role in our study. So maybe I'll just kind of take, walk back just for a minute. And what we are looking for is these individuals who have this outstanding memory performance. And then we ask them to enroll in our research study where we're looking from multiple perspectives. And one of those
到目前为止，我们已经筛选了数千人。我们确实认为“超级老龄化”是一种罕见的表型。我们认为它不是主流，用我们的话说，它并不常见。所以您有兴趣找出是什么让这些“超级老人”与其他人区分开来，而您采用的方法之一是脑成像研究。您发现了什么？“超级老人”的大脑与那些记忆力正常的人有何不同？我们让“超级老人”参与我们的研究。也许我先退后一步。我们寻找的是那些拥有出色记忆表现的个体。然后我们邀请他们参加我们的研究，从多个角度进行观察。其中一个
perspectives is through what's the structure of their brain look like. So does their brain look more like an 80-year-old brain of individuals that they match in chronologic age to? Or does it look more like a 50 to 60-year-old brain who these people match in cognitive performance to. And so one way we can do that is with something called structural MRI or structural magnetic resonance imaging. And so we're getting a 3D image of the brain. And we have a sophisticated computer software program that allows us to reconstruct those images and then look in a very detailed way at the outer layer of the brain and then what we call the gray-white junction. And then we measure the distance between that outer surface of the brain and what we call the gray-white junction, which is kind of like the
角度是观察他们大脑的结构。他们的大脑看起来更像与他们实际年龄相符的80岁人的大脑吗？还是更像与他们认知表现相符的50到60岁人的大脑？实现这一点的方法之一是使用结构性核磁共振成像（MRI）。我们得到了大脑的3D图像。我们有一个复杂的计算机软件程序，可以让我们重建这些图像，然后非常详细地观察大脑的外层，以及我们所说的“灰白质交界处”。然后我们测量大脑外表面与我们所说的“灰白质交界处”之间的距离，这有点像
bark on a tree. And if we measure the thickness there, we get a proxy measure of the health of the brain. The outer layer, that bark of the tree is where the brain cells live. And so getting that proxy measure of cortical thickness can tell us about the health. And we know that with aging on average, our brains tend to become thinner or atrophied with time. When we started out to do this study, we looked at, well, what is the thickness of the superagers compared to 50 to 60 year olds? What is the thickness of the average 80 year olds compared to 50 to 60 year olds? And when we look at average 50 to 60 year olds compared to average, cognitively average 80 year olds, we see that there's significant thinning or shrinkage of the brain in those
树皮。如果我们测量那里的厚度，我们就能得到大脑健康状况的代理指标。外层，也就是树皮，是脑细胞居住的地方。因此，获得皮层厚度的代理指标可以告诉我们大脑的健康状况。我们知道，随着衰老，平均而言，我们的大脑会随着时间的推移变得更薄或萎缩。当我们开始这项研究时，我们观察了“超级老人”与50到60岁人群的厚度对比。普通80岁老人与50到60岁人群的厚度对比又是如何？当我们观察普通的50到60岁人群与认知能力普通的80岁人群时，我们看到那些
cognitively average 80 year olds. And that change has been associated then with those changes in our thinking abilities like memory. When we compare the super age of brains to the 50 to 60 year olds, we see that there was no significant cortical thinning. So this was really shocking to us to say, wow, their brains look more like 50 to 60 year old brains than they do like 80 year old brains. And then we found something even more surprising is that when we looked in the inner surface of the brain in a place called the anterior cingulate, we actually
认知能力普通的80岁老人大脑有明显的变薄或萎缩。这种变化随后与我们思维能力（如记忆力）的变化相关联。当我们比较“超级老人”的大脑与50到60岁人群的大脑时，我们发现没有明显的皮层变薄。这让我们感到非常震惊，因为他们的大脑看起来更像50到60岁人的大脑，而不是80岁人的大脑。然后我们发现了一些更令人惊讶的事情：当我们观察大脑内表面一个叫做“前扣带回”的地方时，我们实际上
saw that the super ages had a thicker anterior cingulate than the 50 to 60 year olds. So there was this one region of the brain that was strikingly thicker than that of their 50 to 60 year old peers, people 20 to 30 years younger than them. Is that something that could be looked at when you're younger to sort of give you an idea of what the future holds for you? If you're 50 and you get one of these brain images, you know, would you be able to see that it's possible you're going to have a good memory when you're 80 or 90 if you live that long? It's a really interesting question and kind of begs the question, well, what happened to super agers' brains? Is it that they were born with thicker brains and they've always been this way?
看到“超级老人”的前扣带回比50到60岁的人更厚。所以大脑中有一个区域比他们年轻20到30岁的同龄人还要明显更厚。当您年轻时，观察这一点是否能让您对未来有所了解？如果您50岁时拍了这样一张脑部扫描图，您能看出自己如果活到80或90岁时，是否有可能拥有良好的记忆力吗？这是一个非常有趣的问题，也引出了一个问题：这些“超级老人”的大脑到底发生了什么？是他们天生大脑就更厚，一直都是这样吗？
Or is it they've just resisted changes to their brains over time? And so we, ideally, what we would have is MRI scans from, you know, birth to age 80 every decade on these individuals to be able to really understand that arc. We don't have that luxury, but what we do have is the superagers come back, over time and participate in this MRI scanning. And when we look longitudinally over time at the rate of shrinkage in the superager's brains, we see that that rate of shrinkage is much slower than that of their 80-plus-year-old cognitively average peers. So this gives us an idea that the superagers are really on a different trajectory than their peers. Their brains seem to be shrinking at a much slower rate. We don't think that the anterior cingulate thickness per se is the fountain of youth or
还是他们只是随着时间的推移抵御了大脑的变化？理想情况下，我们希望拥有这些个体从出生到80岁每十年的MRI扫描图，以便真正了解这一轨迹。我们没有这种奢侈，但我们确实有“超级老人”随着时间的推移回来参与MRI扫描。当我们纵向观察“超级老人”大脑萎缩的速度时，我们发现这种萎缩速度比他们80岁以上认知能力普通的同龄人要慢得多。这让我们意识到，“超级老人”确实处于与同龄人不同的轨迹上。他们的大脑似乎以慢得多的速度萎缩。我们并不认为前扣带回的厚度本身就是青春之泉或
the one thing that dictates why they have great memory. It may be a contributor. And so, you know, often people will say, well, you know, what is that anterior cingulate? What does it do? Why do we have one? How do I get one? Do I want mine to be thicker? And we're starting to understand what role that might be playing in the super agers. But we do know that the anterior singlet is really important for attention. And attention, of course, supports memory. So it's not possible to remember something if you're not paying attention to it. What about other factors such as lifestyle? Are superagers you study? They generally, people who exercised a lot or ate well, do they have stress-free lives? Are there those differences that may be contributing to why their memories are as good as they are?
决定他们为何拥有出色记忆力的唯一因素。它可能是一个贡献者。所以，人们经常会问：“那个前扣带回是什么？它有什么作用？为什么我们有一个？我怎么才能拥有一个？我希望我的更厚吗？”我们开始了解它在“超级老人”中可能发挥的作用。但我们确实知道，前扣带回对注意力非常重要。当然，注意力支持记忆。如果你不注意某件事，就不可能记住它。那么生活方式等其他因素呢？您研究的“超级老人”通常是那些经常锻炼或饮食健康的人吗？他们是否过着无压力的生活？是否存在这些可能导致他们记忆力如此之好的差异？
We are really interested in both the biologic factors and also the lifestyle factors of the super aging program. And what we can say anecdotally right now is that not all superagers exercise. Many of them report doing so, and some of them in various ways. So one person may be leading their stretching class. We have another individual who likes to bike hundreds of miles. So that would be kind of on the opposite end of the spectrum. And we have had individuals, so sometimes we'll ask them, why do you think you're a superager and to get their thoughts about how they stayed so cognitively healthy?
我们对“超级老龄化”计划中的生物学因素和生活方式因素都非常感兴趣。目前我们可以从轶事中说的是，并非所有的“超级老人”都锻炼。许多人报告说他们锻炼，有些人以各种方式锻炼。一个人可能在带拉伸课。我们还有另一个人喜欢骑行数百英里。所以这处于光谱的对立面。我们确实有一些个体，有时我们会问他们：“你认为为什么你是‘超级老人’？”以了解他们关于如何保持如此认知健康的看法。
And I've definitely had more than one superager say, well, it's certainly not because I exercise. I've never exercised and I only run when I'm chased. So I think there's some diversity there. It's not that everybody has had that path. So I don't say that to say that we should all become couch potatoes. But I do highlight that to say, and we certainly know that there's tremendous brain benefit to and cardiovascular benefit to exercising. So I don't want to give that message.
我绝对不止一次听到“超级老人”说：“嗯，肯定不是因为我锻炼。我从不锻炼，我只有在被追赶时才跑。”所以我认为这其中存在一些多样性。并不是每个人都走过那条路。我这么说并不是为了建议我们都应该变成“沙发土豆”。但我强调这一点是为了说明，我们当然知道锻炼对大脑和心血管有巨大的好处。所以我不想传达那种信息。
But I think it is important to know that from a lifestyle perspective, there are different paths that people have taken with exercise. We do think that the super ages are relatively active. So we find that many of them are still working. sometimes at their first career path and other times at a second career path. We have a superager who in what he likes to call his first career, he was a lawyer. And then he retired, got bored, and then went back and got certified to do taxes seasonally and found that that was a great balance for him, that he was really busy for part of the year
但我认为重要的是要知道，从生活方式的角度来看，人们在锻炼方面采取了不同的路径。我们确实认为“超级老人”相对活跃。我们发现他们中的许多人仍在工作，有时是在他们的第一职业道路上，有时是在第二职业道路上。我们有一位“超级老人”，在他所谓的“第一职业”中，他是一名律师。然后他退休了，感到无聊，又回去考取了季节性税务申报的资格，并发现这对他是很好的平衡，他在一年中的一部分时间里非常忙碌，
and then had the rest of the year to relax. And if I'm remembering correctly, was one of the most requested. helpers during tax season. So I think these are some of the lifestyle factors that we're interested in. The super aging study, although it's more than a decade old, we still are in some ways just hitting our prime. And there's a lot of unanswered questions. And we'll probably, maybe we'll touch on this a little bit later, but we really are excited about some new directions that we're going. And one path that we're going down is going to ask the super ages to wear, monitor, something like your Fitbit, but they'll be a little bit smaller, that will actually start to track the activity of the superagers. It'll also track sleep so that we can better
然后一年中剩下的时间可以放松。如果我没记错的话，他是税务季节最受欢迎的帮手之一。所以我认为这些是我们感兴趣的一些生活方式因素。“超级老龄化”研究虽然已经进行了十多年，但在某些方面我们才刚刚进入黄金时期。还有很多未解之谜。我们可能稍后会谈到这一点，但我们对正在进行的一些新方向感到非常兴奋。我们正在进行的一条路径是要求“超级老人”佩戴监测器，类似于Fitbit，但会小一点，这将开始追踪“超级老人”的活动。它还会追踪睡眠，以便我们能更好地
understand, not just anecdotally, but what do we see? What's different about their interactions? And the last thing I'll kind of touch on from a lifestyle or personality perspective is that superagers report having stronger positive relationships with others compared to their cognitively average peers who are also in the study that we did were reporting strong positive relationships with others, but the superager has really superseded that, so an even higher level. And this finding, again, we haven't quite we haven't uncovered yet. Well, is that because they have two close friends or do they constantly have a group of people that they are with? And I think that is going to end up
理解，不仅仅是凭轶事，而是我们看到了什么？他们的互动有什么不同？关于生活方式或个性，我要提到的最后一点是，“超级老人”报告说，与研究中认知能力普通的同龄人相比，他们与他人的积极关系更强。那些同龄人也报告了与他人的强有力积极关系，但“超级老人”确实超越了这一点，达到了更高的水平。这一发现，我们还没有完全揭示。是因为他们有两个亲密朋友，还是他们身边一直有一群人？我认为这最终会
being at the individual level and your personality preferences of do you really enjoy large groups or small groups and having a few close trusted friends. But we'll be able to get at some of those things by the newer studies that we have planned. What are those social interactions like? We know this is critically important because of the negative consequences of social isolation and loneliness. And I think that's all too familiar to us right now, having been through a pandemic where we've had to often be away from friends and family and those that we hold dear. Well, it's interesting that relationships would have that impact on memory. I mean, you expect it to have an impact on sort of overall well-being, but the memory key there
归结为个人层面和你的个性偏好，即你是否真的喜欢大群体，还是喜欢小群体和几个值得信赖的亲密朋友。但通过我们计划的新研究，我们将能够触及其中一些问题。这些社交互动是什么样的？我们知道这至关重要，因为社会孤立和孤独会带来负面后果。我认为这对我们来说现在太熟悉了，因为我们经历了一场大流行，我们经常不得不远离朋友、家人和我们珍视的人。嗯，人际关系会对记忆产生这种影响很有趣。我的意思是，你期望它对整体幸福感产生影响，但记忆的关键点
is important. Well, let me ask you another question. I'll personalize it a little bit. So I have an aunt who's 90, and I think she'd qualify as a super age. She remembers everything. She's very, very sharp. But her brother, who is two or three years younger, has experienced severe memory loss, and it started some years ago. And I know this is just one isolated example, but is there a genetic component? Are you looking at siblings? Do you know? Do you see in families that if one person is a superager, that you'll see other superagers in the same family? Genetics is another component that is of interest to us in the superagers. And I think the way that we've thought about genetics has really evolved over the last decade, if not longer. So we may have thought about genetics more simplistically a decade or two ago that, oh, shoot,
很重要。好吧，让我问您另一个问题。我把它个人化一点。我有一位90岁的姑姑，我认为她有资格成为“超级老人”。她记得一切。她非常、非常敏锐。但她比她小两三岁的弟弟却经历了严重的记忆丧失，而且几年前就开始了。我知道这只是一个孤立的例子，但有遗传成分吗？您在研究兄弟姐妹吗？您知道吗？您是否在家庭中看到，如果一个人是“超级老人”，您会在同一个家庭中看到其他“超级老人”？遗传学是我们在“超级老人”中感兴趣的另一个组成部分。我认为我们思考遗传学的方式在过去十年甚至更长时间里确实发生了演变。所以我们可能在十二十年前更简单地思考遗传学，认为“哎呀，
if I didn't have picked the right parents, then I'm out of luck. And we now know that things are much more complicated than that. And specifically, just to start with your question is I love hearing the stories of, I have a brother or a sister or an aunt or an uncle or a parent who would qualify for the study. And that's really how we get a lot of people involved in the study is through that word of mouth referral. But to speak to your point specifically, we do take a detailed family history on all the super ages who enroll in the study. And we see that there are some that have longevity in their family, while others do have a family history of dementia or other medical histories in their family. So this is something that we also take into account when we're thinking about how many medications,
如果我没有选对父母，那我就倒霉了。”我们现在知道事情比那复杂得多。具体来说，从您的问题开始，我喜欢听那些“我有兄弟姐妹、姑姑、叔叔或父母有资格参加这项研究”的故事。这确实是我们让很多人参与研究的方式，通过口碑推荐。但具体说到您的一点，我们确实对所有参加研究的“超级老人”进行了详细的家族史调查。我们看到有些人家族中有长寿基因，而另一些人家族中有痴呆症或其他病史。所以这也是我们在考虑他们服用多少药物时考虑到的因素，
are they taking? Is it different than their peers? And we're finalizing a study on that right now. So the role of genetics is likely to not be a single gene that is your super aged or gene, but more complex than that. And so we are actively pursuing studies to understand what are those genetic components and how is this playing a role? And it's possible for some individuals that their genetic profile is helping them eat their hamburgs and french fries every day without having as great deleterious effects. And others, it may have been more important that they've chosen certain lifestyle factors that have gotten them where they are. So this is a really exciting part as the superaging program has matured because genetic studies really require larger
他们服用药物吗？这与他们的同龄人不同吗？我们目前正在完成一项关于此的研究。因此，遗传学的作用很可能不是单一的“超级老人”基因，而是比这更复杂。因此，我们正在积极开展研究，以了解这些遗传成分是什么，以及它如何发挥作用。对于某些个体来说，他们的遗传特征可能帮助他们每天吃汉堡和炸薯条而没有产生那么大的有害影响。而对另一些人来说，他们选择的某些生活方式因素可能更重要，才让他们达到了现在的状态。所以这是“超级老龄化”计划成熟后一个非常令人兴奋的部分，因为遗传学研究确实需要更大的
numbers of participants. And if we kind of think back to the beginning, beginning when I told you super aging is kind of rare. So it's been hard to get the numbers to start and really dig deep in those genetic studies. I'm wondering about the relationship of physical health problems and people who age. Do you see that superagers tend on average to be somewhat healthier? Is there any relationship between that and just the fact that their memory is as good as it is? Yeah. So physical health is so important. And when we really think about the term super aging versus the term successful aging, which is just this idea that doesn't have a specific definition, many studies of successful aging, which was a great idea that was promoted by Rowan Khan
参与者数量。如果我们回想一下开始时，当我告诉您“超级老龄化”有点罕见。所以很难获得足够的数量来开始并深入挖掘这些遗传研究。我想知道身体健康问题与衰老人群之间的关系。您是否发现“超级老人”平均而言身体更健康一些？这与他们的记忆力如此之好之间有什么关系吗？是的。所以身体健康非常重要。当我们真正思考“超级老龄化”与“成功老龄化”这两个术语时，“成功老龄化”只是一个没有具体定义的想法，许多关于成功老龄化的研究，这是一个由罗恩·卡恩在
a few decades ago and really was an important turning point in thinking about the positive aspects of aging. Many of the studies that came to follow after this idea of successful aging required that individuals have great physical health, but also great memory performance or good cognitive performance, but really paired together cognitive performance and physical performance. We specifically require that superagers have good memory performance, but do not make any requirement about physical performance because some people might need a wheelchair or a walker, but still have great memory performance. And that's exactly what we find is that there's really a range of physical performance
几十年前推广的伟大想法，确实是思考衰老积极方面的关键转折点。许多在“成功老龄化”这一想法之后的研究要求个体拥有良好的身体健康，同时也拥有良好的记忆表现或良好的认知表现，但确实将认知表现和身体表现结合在一起。我们特别要求“超级老人”拥有良好的记忆表现，但不对身体表现做任何要求，因为有些人可能需要轮椅或助行器，但仍然拥有出色的记忆表现。这正是我们发现的，即我们的“超级老人”的身体表现
and physical capabilities in our super-agers. And so that allows us to study those things in more depth. This is another area that we will be exploring with more quantitative data in the future. Yeah. So I think, and then from an overall well-being standpoint, as far as medical history, we have not seen anything particularly notable between the super-agers and the cognitively average group that we follow. What about education level?
和身体能力确实存在范围。这使我们能够更深入地研究这些事情。这是我们未来将用更多定量数据探索的另一个领域。是的。所以我想，从整体幸福感的角度来看，就病史而言，我们在我们跟踪的“超级老人”和认知能力普通的群体之间没有看到任何特别值得注意的事情。教育水平呢？
Does that play any kind of a role? I mean, I've seen research that talks about people who, you know, do better, who age better, as you were talking about. If they're more intellectually stimulated and involved, that that makes a difference. Are you seeing that with your superagers, too? Yeah, there's a few things packed in there that you said. So one is education. And there's certainly been many studies talking about the importance of education as potentially
这起什么作用吗？我的意思是，我见过研究谈论那些，你知道，表现更好，衰老得更好的人，正如您所说的那样。如果他们受到更多的智力刺激和参与，那会有所不同。您在您的“超级老人”身上也看到了这一点吗？是的，您说的内容里包含了几件事。一是教育。当然有很多研究谈论教育的重要性，认为它可能
being a protective factor. We haven't specifically made an association with superagers in a certain level of education. I can report that our superagers range in education from 12 years to 20 years. And I think the important thing to note there is that not all superagers are overeducated in that we haven't just enrolled doctors and lawyers and people with advanced degrees, that there is somewhat of a range, although that range at this point doesn't fall below a high school level of education. That could change in the future and may have to do with research bias in finding individuals. Maybe we need to change our kind of recruitment practices to find other people.
是一种保护因素。我们还没有专门将“超级老人”与特定水平的教育联系起来。我可以报告说，我们的“超级老人”的教育程度从12年到20年不等。我认为值得注意的是，并非所有的“超级老人”都受过过度教育，我们并没有只招募医生、律师和拥有高级学位的人，确实存在一定的范围，尽管这个范围目前没有低于高中教育水平。这在未来可能会改变，可能与寻找个体的研究偏见有关。也许我们需要改变我们的招聘方式来寻找其他人。
So I can't really comment on super-agers in education other than to say that we have that range of education. But cognitive stimulation was the other thing that you brought up. And we do know that our brain really loves to stay active. So a common question is when I give a talk about the superagers is, you know, should I still be doing crossword puzzles and what about lumosity or what about this brain training program? And should I take, you know, this supplement? And my response commonly is, well, do you like crossword? puzzles? Are they easy for you or are they challenging for you? If they're easy for you,
所以我不能真正评论“超级老人”和教育，只能说我们有那个教育范围。但认知刺激是您提到的另一件事。我们确实知道我们的大脑非常喜欢保持活跃。所以当我谈论“超级老人”时，一个常见的问题是：“我应该继续做填字游戏吗？Lumosity怎么样？或者这个大脑训练程序怎么样？我应该服用这个补充剂吗？”我的回答通常是：“嗯，你喜欢填字游戏吗？它们对你来说很容易，还是很有挑战性？如果它们对你来说很容易，
you're probably not getting much brain benefit because our brains like to be challenged. If you don't like them and they bring you a lot of angst, you're probably not getting much brain benefit from them because the stress that's caused by your, in the dread that you feel when you're like, I got to work on my crossword puzzle today is going to far outweigh any brain benefit. So there's there's some really lovely work that was done by Denise Park several years ago where she did a really elegant study where there was, she trained, there was three different groups. One group was trained to knit, I believe. The other group was trained to do photography in a class. And then there was another control group. And the question was, you know, was knitting or
你可能没有得到太多大脑益处，因为我们的大脑喜欢被挑战。如果你不喜欢它们，它们给你带来很多焦虑，你可能没有从中得到太多大脑益处，因为当你觉得‘我今天必须做填字游戏’时所产生的压力和恐惧将远远超过任何大脑益处。”所以丹妮丝·帕克几年前做了一些非常可爱的研究，她做了一项非常优雅的研究，她训练了三个不同的组。一组被训练编织，我相信。另一组被训练在课堂上摄影。然后还有另一个对照组。问题是，你知道，编织还是
photography better. And they found kind of equal brain benefit from each of those activities. And I think the key point there is that it was the act of learning something new and staying engaged that makes our brain respond. So my general advice is find something that challenges you and that is exciting to you and focus on that. You've talked publicly about how personally rewarding you find it to spend time with superagers in your study and even outside of the research questions that you get to explore. What has made that aspect of your work so fulfilling? Gosh, it's just such a privilege that these individuals who have a lot to do and are very busy, choose to spend their time giving back. So this is a truly altruistic act to participate in research and to keep coming
摄影更好？他们发现每种活动都有类似的大脑益处。我认为关键点在于，学习新事物并保持参与的行为使我们的大脑做出反应。所以我的一般建议是：找到挑战你并让你兴奋的事情，专注于此。您曾公开谈论过您在研究中与“超级老人”共度时光，甚至在您探索的研究问题之外，您个人觉得有多么有意义。是什么让您工作的这一方面如此充实？天哪，这些个体有很多事情要做，非常忙碌，却选择花时间回馈，这真是一种荣幸。所以参与研究并坚持回来
back year after a year and then eventually at the time of death they're giving us that ultimate gift of donating their brain the majority of them so that we can really understand those cellular and molecular features and in advance the science. But on a personal note, the wisdom and grit and adaptability and resilience that these individuals offer I think is so instructive. And they give you hope and ammunition to redefine expectations when we think about aging and thinking about how do we reduce stigma. And so I think of it as an honor to have that opportunity. It was early on in the superaging study where I think maybe the right word is demand. The super ages demanded that they wanted to meet each other or strong.
年复一年，最终在去世时给我们捐赠大脑这一终极礼物，他们中的大多数人这样做，以便我们能够真正了解那些细胞和分子特征并推进科学，这确实是一种利他行为。但从个人角度来看，这些个体提供的智慧、毅力、适应性和韧性我认为非常有启发性。他们给你希望和弹药来重新定义我们思考衰老时的期望，并思考我们如何减少污名化。所以我认为有机会这样做是一种荣誉。在“超级老龄化”研究的早期，我想也许合适的词是“要求”。“超级老人”要求他们想见面，或者强烈
strongly suggested and said, when are we having a party? We want to get together. And if you know anything about NIH funding, there's no party money. So we had to think of some creative mechanisms to bring the superagers together. And we've now had three super aging parties. And each one has been just truly remarkable and an opportunity to slow down and step away from wearing my research hat. and just have the opportunity to connect and watch those connections being made between superagers, too, has been really fun. So you recently received a National Institute of Aging Grant to expand your Super Aging Study beyond Chicago, right,
建议并说：“我们什么时候聚会？我们想聚在一起。”如果你了解NIH的资助，就没有聚会资金。所以我们必须想出一些创造性的机制来把“超级老人”聚在一起。我们现在已经举办了三次“超级老龄化”聚会。每一次都非常了不起，是一个放慢脚步、放下研究者身份的机会，只是有机会建立联系，看着“超级老人”之间建立联系，也真的很有趣。所以您最近获得了国家老龄化研究所的资助，将您的“超级老龄化”研究扩展到芝加哥之外，对吧，
and to several new sites in the U.S. and in Canada. So what are you hoping to explore with the new funding? Where are you expanding for listeners who might be interested in maybe participating, you know, what cities and towns you're going to be in? Yes, we are very excited about this. So the majority of the superaging study has, you know, the hub, of course, has been in Chicago. And we've had the rare superager who maybe has traveled to participate in this study from outside of the Chicago land area, but the majority have been in Chicago so far. So we're really excited to say that we're expanding internationally, we like to say, but it's across the U.S. and Canada. So there'll be five sites now.
并扩展到美国和加拿大的几个新地点。那么您希望通过新的资金探索什么？对于可能感兴趣参与的听众，您将去哪些城市和城镇？是的，我们对此感到非常兴奋。所以“超级老龄化”研究的大部分，你知道，中心当然一直在芝加哥。我们有罕见的“超级老人”可能从芝加哥地区以外的地方旅行来参与这项研究，但到目前为止，大多数都在芝加哥。所以我们很高兴地说，我们正在国际化，我们喜欢这样说，但它跨越了美国和加拿大。所以现在将有五个地点。
One of them in Michigan at the University of Michigan, the University of Wisconsin, Emory University and Atlanta, and then we have a partnership with a few different universities, including Waterloo and Western University in Canada. And the focus of the superaging study is, you know, first and foremost to expand in the regions that we're looking for superagers with a particular focus on identifying people of color, so that there is more diversity in the super aging sample. So that's really important for understanding generalization of what factors may play into different paths of being a superager and how does race, ethnicity, or sex contribute to those factors. And so this will allow us to do that.
其中一个在密歇根大学，威斯康星大学，亚特兰大的埃默里大学，然后我们与几所不同的大学建立了合作伙伴关系，包括加拿大的滑铁卢大学和西安大略大学。“超级老龄化”研究的重点是，首先也是最重要的，是在我们寻找“超级老人”的地区进行扩展，特别关注识别有色人种，以便“超级老龄化”样本中有更多的多样性。所以这对于理解“超级老人”不同路径的影响因素的普遍性非常重要，种族、民族或性别如何影响这些因素。所以这将使我们能够做到这一点。
We're also expanding. So the superagers program, or this initiative will allow us to have more depth and breadth in the science that we cover. So I mentioned a little bit earlier that one of the key projects will be asking this better understanding the sleep and activity and social interaction of the super agers by asking them to wear these Fitbit like sensors. And then we have other studies focused on the genetic aspects of super aging and what role does inflammation play. we're able to go in greater depth and breadth on the imaging studies that we can do and understanding not only the structure of the brain but how it's functioning. And so these are some of the exciting areas that we're looking into next. I know in addition to your work on the super aging study that you study different forms of dementia
我们也在扩展。所以“超级老人”计划，或者这个倡议将使我们在我们涵盖的科学方面有更多的深度和广度。所以我刚才提到，关键项目之一将是要求更好地理解“超级老人”的睡眠、活动和社交互动，通过要求他们佩戴这些类似Fitbit的传感器。然后我们有其他研究专注于“超级老龄化”的遗传方面，炎症发挥什么作用。我们能够对我们可以进行的成像研究进行更深入和广泛的研究，不仅了解大脑的结构，还了解它是如何运作的。所以这些是我们接下来要研究的一些令人兴奋的领域。我知道除了您在“超级老龄化”研究上的工作外，您还研究不同形式的痴呆症
and interventions for dementia. Is there anything that we might learn from the super aging study that will help the effort to fight or treat dementia? Absolutely. So when we think about the superaging study and why are we doing it, I think there's really important rationale. So one is that as a medical community, we've gotten good at extending our lifespan. So you mentioned that in the intro to this segment, that the above 85 plus population is really accelerating. But what's happening is our lifespan is lengthening is that it's not always keeping pace with our health span.
和痴呆症的干预措施。我们能从“超级老龄化”研究中学到什么来帮助对抗或治疗痴呆症的努力吗？绝对可以。所以当我们思考“超级老龄化”研究以及我们为什么要进行它时，我认为确实有非常重要的理由。所以一是作为医学界，我们已经擅长延长我们的寿命。所以您在这一部分的介绍中提到了，85岁以上的人口确实在加速增长。但正在发生的是，我们的寿命在延长，但它并不总是与我们的健康寿命保持同步。
And so I think superagers represent a good balance of lifespan and health span. And people don't want to just live long. They want to live long and live well. Just like that, the superaging study offers us a window into studying Alzheimer's and different factors. So one way to study Alzheimer's disease is to identify the individuals who have Alzheimer's disease and then say, what's going wrong and how would we reverse that? another approach, and that approach is really important, so I don't want to discount that. But another approach is to say, well, how have some people avoided this? And I think the superagers represent that a little bit.
所以我认为“超级老人”代表了寿命和健康寿命的良好平衡。人们不想只是活得长。他们想活得长且活得好。就像那样，“超级老龄化”研究为我们提供了一个研究阿尔茨海默病和不同因素的窗口。所以研究阿尔茨海默病的一种方法是识别患有阿尔茨海默病的个体，然后说：“出了什么问题，我们如何逆转它？”另一种方法，这种方法确实很重要，所以我不想忽视它。但另一种方法是说：“嗯，有些人是如何避免这种情况的？”我认为“超级老人”在一定程度上代表了这一点。
So when we, Alzheimer's disease is very, very complex. And what we know is that the plaques and tangles that defined Alzheimer's disease are actually commonly found in 80-plus-year-old individuals. Now, do the super-ageers, we've seen that the super-ageers, we've seen that the super-ageers, tend to have fewer of those tangles than would even be expected for average 80-plus-year-olds. Why is that? How did they avoid the development? How did they resist the development of those plaques and tangles?
所以当我们，阿尔茨海默病非常、非常复杂。我们所知道的是，定义阿尔茨海默病的斑块和缠结实际上在80岁以上的个体中很常见。现在，“超级老人”是否，我们已经看到“超级老人”，我们已经看到“超级老人”，往往比普通80岁以上的老人预期的缠结更少。为什么会这样？他们是如何避免发展的？他们是如何抵御那些斑块和缠结的发展的？
And what factors drove that? Similarly, there are some individuals who do have more pathologic features than what we would expect for their age. And so it's like, well, how did these factors not have as great of enough? effect? You know, how are they resilient to the effects of what we thought would be negative consequences of aging? And so they really offer a window into thinking about resilience and resistance and what those protective factors may be. Lots and lots of open questions there. So just to wrap up, if there are listeners among us who are, they think they might be potential participants in your study or know people who could participate,
是什么因素推动了这一点？同样，有些人确实比我们预期的年龄有更多的病理特征。所以就像，“嗯，这些因素怎么没有产生那么大的影响？”你知道，他们如何对我们认为会是衰老负面后果的影响产生韧性？所以他们确实提供了一个思考韧性和抵抗力以及那些保护因素可能是什么的窗口。那里有很多很多悬而未决的问题。所以最后，如果我们的听众中有，他们认为他们可能是您研究的潜在参与者，或者认识可以参与的人，
Where do they go to get more information and get screened? Sure. We would love to have them come to our website, which is brain.northwestern.edu. And we have a registry there that they can fill out a few questions and then someone can reach back out and try and find a match for a study. And I should mention, because we are an aging and dementia research center, we do more than super aging research. So even if you're not over age 80 and you are interested in research, or if you just want to join our newsletter to hear about the work that we're doing, we encourage you to visit us there and join our registry. Well, thank you, Dr. Rogowski. This has been very interesting. I really appreciate you taking the time to talk to us. Thank you for having me.
他们去哪里获取更多信息并进行筛选？当然。我们很乐意让他们访问我们的网站，即brain.northwestern.edu。我们在那里有一个注册表，他们可以填写几个问题，然后有人可以联系并尝试为研究找到匹配项。我应该提到，因为我们是一个衰老和痴呆症研究中心，我们做的不仅仅是“超级老龄化”研究。所以即使你不到80岁，你对研究感兴趣，或者如果你只是想加入我们的通讯以了解我们正在做的工作，我们鼓励你访问我们并加入我们的注册表。嗯，谢谢您，罗加尔斯基博士。这非常有趣。我真的很感谢您花时间与我们交谈。谢谢邀请我。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcast. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站www.apa.org/podcast上，或者在Apple、Stitcher或您获取最喜爱播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。